pour arrêter les politiques d'austérité
de lecture votre lecture du soir
vous rappelez d'été candidat en 2000
campagne compliquée pour les soutiens de
jacques cheminade dans les yvelines
ils sont confrontés au manque de
popularité de leur candidat selon les
derniers sondages ils ne dépassent pas
la barre des 1% l'année
je le connais pas et puis bah je n'ai
même pas entendu parler je sais pas du
tout donc je vais juste dire déjà savoir
mais je ne connais pas puisqu'ils
viennent m'en parler et je vais
documenté je veux dire il gérait un peu
plus sur sur un site où je vais voir ce
que ce qu'il a à proposer et à dire quoi
jacky minaj elle est connue depuis pas
mal d'années à travers à travers les
médias et c'est quelqu'un qui a fait
qu'un énorme des bonnes idées mais
malheureusement je pense qu'ils se
réveillent un petit peu trop tard avec
tout ce qui se passe actuellement au
sein des médias concernant pas mal d des
candidats autre difficulté le vote utile
de plus en plus évoquée par les
électeurs je vais pas voter pour
monsieur chamiers chemina je vais
essayer d'ajouter je vais vous dire
pourquoi parce que j'ai très peur
concernant le programme plusieurs
mesures économiques sous le slogan
libérez les français de l'occupation
financière au lieu d'utiliser l'argent
des gens et l'argent de l'état pour
sauver les banques
on veut séparer la partie banque
d'affaires pour la laisser assumer ses
dettes tout seul sans la renflouer et
que l'état retrouve le moyen de
contrôler que l'état retrouve le
contrôle sur sa monnaie pour financer
les politiques de développement en 2012
jacques cheminade avait recueilli près
de 0,3 pour cent des suffrages dans les
yvelines